you'll have to listen to me for another
20 or 30 minutes and then yujang will
take over and tell you about logic
circuits
I did manage during the break to collect
a few uh misunderstandings that are
crucial uh that I would like to do a
better job of explaining
um so there's two key questions I think
people have one is if you factorize
things why do you still have
dependencies and the second confusion is
what is happening with there being
multiple gaussians that have the same
random variable name this is confusing
okay so here we have a simple uh
probabilistic circuit the way to read it
is to say that
um somehow three quarters of all people
are in California uh one quarter of all
people are in Belgium
and when you're in California there's
independent probabilities independent
coin flips saying that the weather is
nice very likely with 90 probability
coin flip and there's an earthquake also
very likely eighty percent probability
don't worry about the numbers
um both are very likely in Belgium both
are very unlikely but they're still
independent of each other okay and so
now the crucial way in which in
processing circuits you build
dependencies is that if I tell you that
uh the weather is nice but I don't tell
you where you are
it means that you're more likely in
California which means it's more likely
that you'll get an earthquake so now
there's a dependence here through that
mixture at the at the root that's some
okay knowing that the weather is nice
tells you something about there being an
earthquake so that's how dependencies
creep into what is otherwise just a
factorization of independent random
variables okay so that's the first point
the second point that needs clarifying
is I was showing you this circuit
without the red lines and I was telling
you well here you have some gaussian
about the weather here you have some
other gaussian about the weather they're
different
kind of hand waving all that stuff so
here you have now two this is actually
just two coin flips that are different
bias for the same random variable if if
you find this annoying just take
whatever variable is the scope here of
the random variable and just make it an
input to the Circuit so now there's one
variable that's the weather and it feeds
into both of these and now if what
you're Computing is a likelihood these
are just multiplications by these
parameters and this is just a classical
arithmetic circuit from your theory
community and this shouldn't look
strange anymore yeah I I find just for
my students I think it's more useful to
understand if you don't just think about
random labels but you also think about
the underlying very hard to understand
probability the probability space so
there is a property it is based under
this whole thing we only can describe it
with a handful of
them I think in terms of uh outcomes in
that topic this basically becomes clear
okay
other questions I hope this helps for
people that were confused
um all right so let's move on I told you
about decomposability
synthetic non-linearity smoothness
never mix things together that are
different units and so now my claim is
that with these two properties on my
circuit I can do arbitrary integrals at
least you know in terms of marginal
probabilities as I show them so um let's
make our problem simple let's say that I
want to compute this integral which if
this is a normalized distribution has to
be one okay
um okay so if it's not it's a
debate somewhere in the middle of the
sets of problems yes that was another
point of uh confusion so if you don't
really know what's beneath here this is
an arbitrary circuit it does have a
scope which is instead of all those
books these have to be disjoint sets
okay
all right
uh good
so how do we do this
um so let's look at this example so we
have a rather simple circuit and we
would like to compute this integral here
we have to or if you like sums you can
think of this as a sum over all possible
worlds where we have to sum up the
probability of all of the Worlds
um now here at the output of our circuit
we have a sum a mixture which is defined
as this kind of weighted sum of inputs
okay and now it's very easy to see that
the integral of the sum is the sum of
the integrals and so that means that if
I'm on a computer's integral here I can
just compute it at the second to last
layer uh two times you know for each of
these circuits and then computer
weighted average and we're done okay so
this is pretty trivial hopefully okay so
that means we have pushed our
integration from the last layer to the
second to last layer now we are hitting
this product uh notes in our circuits
when you have a product note we assumed
the decomposability property and so that
means that is very large integral which
is summing over all values of x y and z
can now be actually written as the
product of integrals separately summing
over all X Y and Z in each of these
circuits separately right so now we can
you know put parentheses here
and we essentially get three integrals
that we're Computing in these
sub-circuits and we multiply these
integrals and we get the answer we want
and so that means that we can take our
integral here push it one layer down one
layer down one layer down one layer down
until we have to compute an integral at
the input distributions which we have
already assumed can be done efficiently
for whatever whatever you want to
consider here the coin flip for example
okay so that's pretty easy of course the
way that we do this is using dynamic
programming in the reverse Direction
just to make it efficient so let's say
we want to compute the probability of
some particular value of X2 and X4 and
we're marginalizing out X1 and X3 okay
so that means that for all of the the
inputs or gaussians that mention X1 and
X3
if I were to push this integral down I
would end up Computing the integral of
of these gaussians and the output would
be one
okay so for these variables
that are being marginalized out I just
replace them by a constant one
okay that's my integral for the other
ones I don't actually integrate over X2
and X4 I'm given specific values for
them
and so that means that I just need to
compute the
probability of these values in each of
these little Atomic circuits
then because of the previous slide it's
all just sums of products of sums of
products I compute it in this forward
fashion and I get my marginal
probability at my outputs for this
particular query and this works no
matter what values you give to X2 and X4
it works no matter which subset of
variables you want to observe
okay pretty easy okay
the value for a particular X plus four
but you want to compute the General
Distribution can you somehow do
something then on the circuit and
compute another circuit
very good so suppose that I I don't
really get values for 2 for X2 and X4 I
just would like to somehow marginalize
all the others out of the circuit and
still get a joint distribution over X2
and X4
all I need to do is
the blue step
this becomes a one which then disappears
this this one disappears also here
essentially you can simplify your
circuit
setting to one all of the things you
don't care about and you're left with a
sub-circuit that is your marginal
distribution
so again I find this actually quite a
very very deep in someone says what
you're seeing here is that you actually
never need to compute the integrals even
for the the leaf notes so if instead of
a gaussian I would have a very
complicated function in a single
variable for which I don't know how to
compute the integral you still
substitute with one because you are
guaranteed to have that integralized
guarantee to be a normalized
yeah uh yeah so suppose you had yeah I
don't know if I can come up with an
instance of where this would happen but
that's true right so you know this is a
normalized distribution so it's one
and you assume you can compute a likeli
density and that's all you need so so
far your assumption that you need to be
able to compute integrates for these
transcendental functions that you put on
the nodes like the gaussian you have not
used it you didn't need to use it right
right we don't actually have to compute
some integral over some interval in the
gaussian to do this but that's also
because we've kind of defined queries as
being values for variables or missing as
soon as you Define marginal queries also
as saying X2 is between 0 and 5 then you
do need to actually compute those
integrals at least which you can do it
it's also tractable okay thanks yeah
of course what we're hiding here is the
fact that Computing integrals for the
gaussian is actually not tractable but
you know in practice of this yeah
yeah all right
uh let's get well okay so something fun
you can do is you know if I give you
images we could already compute the
probability of that image in the
distribution but if you're now only
given the bottom half of some image you
can also compute the probability of the
bottom half of that image exactly and
efficiently okay
um
because we can compute marginals we can
now compute conditional probabilities I
guess it's rather straightforward it's
just a ratio of two marginals and for
reasons I won't actually really explain
once you can compute a conditional
probability you can also just sample
from that conditional distribution and
so now here you have from a particular
probabilistic circuit that was trained
on mnist you get some sampled
completions of these lower half images
okay
computer efficient people like to see uh
these kind of silly experiments not on
mnist I think they like they like
fancier images but whatever okay
um and so now I want to take a little
detour because uh very early on someone
asked why do you even care about
Computing marginals you know if all you
want is generate images or generate text
you don't really need marginals right so
here's my answer to that question
um and the the main takeaway here is
that so there will be no Theory here
it's just kind of motivation for why we
care the main story here is that when we
use generative models like stable
diffusion or chat GPT or whatever it's
still very difficult to control these
models and what they generate right so
here I ask for more reasoning and I get
more recession right so that's not what
I want so let's go to a chat GPT I want
to say generate a sentence using frisbee
caught and dog following this given
order
right not that hard of a question uh
first answer is not exactly correct I
mean it's English but it doesn't follow
the order of the keywords that I I
specified okay and so as always with uh
with uh language models you have to
insist and say no no please do it
correctly and you have to kind of beg
until it does it what you want you say
no do it do it correctly and then still
it gets it wrong okay and so still you
know it's kind of difficult even though
these models are extremely powerful to
actually get them to do exactly what you
want
and so um at icml last month or so we
presented a system called gelato which
is generating things that are always
guaranteed to satisfy these constraints
you can generate things that that always
have the property you want it generates
the obvious thing which is frisbee is
called by a dog but it also generates
this kind of acute solution a pair of
frisbee players are caught in a dog
fights which I find kind of nice
um
and so the main takeaway I'll show you a
few slides but since you're not machine
Learners you probably don't care too
much but the main takeaway is this is
using marginal inference in a
probabilistic circuit to actually
guide the language model to generate
things that are correct
okay
um so a quick detour to language models
what they're doing is capturing a
distribution by just taking the prefix
and then predicting the next token
recursively okay autoregressive models
and so for example when you have a
prefix that says the weather is
then it doesn't really know whether it
should say cold or warm roughly equal
probability okay however if if I would
really like to generate something that
has the word winter in it eventually
later on then obviously the weather is
cold should be a much more likely next
token than the weather is warm but
there's really no way currently to tell
these models like no I want you to
generate the next token with the end
goal of giving certain uh certain other
kind of pieces of text or syntax or
whatever
and so what you need is to generate from
this conditional token distribution that
says given the prefix and the
constraints how do I predict the next
token okay and there of course gold will
be much more likely than warm and you
will actually reach your goal as you
generate language
this is nothing but marginalization I
have to sum over all future text
and computes how often do I get my next
token given my prefix and the
constraints and if I know this then I
know what the distribution of our next
tokens is okay and so marginalization
even though I kind of treated it as this
kind of silly query you would ask about
traffic in La it's it's the essence of
this problem
okay
um and
yeah not sure how much you care about
these details but essentially the in
this particular system called gelato
um we support arbitrary cnfs as
constraints that are of this form
um where you say I would like to
generate a sentence that has the
keywords swims or like swimming and lake
or pool moreover these keywords can
appear in any position or in a certain
specified order so there's this there's
a little
language
you'll agree this is probably a language
right a simple language where you can
specify like these goals of your
generative model uh and it's it's
guaranteed to get it right and so
for a uh a simple prostic circuit that's
really just a very much scaled up hidden
Markov model
um you can compute the probability of
these queries and also sample conditions
on these types of constraints in time
linear in your sequence length and
so here there's no order but if you want
to you can also specify an order you can
also specify a specific position these
are just different versions of the same
constraints yeah
it guarantees to get it right because I
mean it never makes a mistake never
makes a mistake
whenever the next token if there's a
next token that if you were to choose it
it would make it impossible for you to
satisfy the constraint it would give it
zero probability
so it's kind of doing logical reasoning
as as a special case of probabilistic
reasoning
um yeah I
so people in natural language processing
like to always treat things through
benchmarks so there's actually Benchmark
for this problem called common gen so
you're given these keywords no drive car
and then you have to generate something
that looks like this it's actually quite
difficult as a logical constraint
because snow doesn't mean snow it means
snowy snow it's all of the inflections
of snow and so there's you know the
constraint is actually quite complicated
and so in this you know how does gelato
work well you still have your GPT
language model which has no idea about
the constraint it just knows about the
next token but then you have your
proposing circuits which is tractable
which can tell you what's the
probability that I will reach my goal
satisfy the constraints given my prefix
and my next token and so this one knows
that yeah colon is actually the thing
that more likely will generate uh winter
eventually
now there's some interesting ways in
which you can combine these models
meaning how do I actually control the
language model which is really good at
English
using the pro 6 circuit which is
slightly worse at English but very good
at marginalization
um there's a few ways to do that but
essentially you can combine them to kind
of get the right answer and also
generate grammatical English
you can check the slides for more
details but the summary here is that
even something very simple like taking
the geometric means between the next
token distributions basically having
them somehow agree on which next words
are both going to reach the goal and be
correct English actually works really
well so this is how NLP folks evaluate
the generated language they select
things like blue scores so these are
very uh well-known NLP papers like this
was a natural best paper Awards
or maybe this one on Europe's oral so
these are all the very recent kind of
systems people build and it turns out
that just doing this very simple
marginalization on a probe 6 circuits
gives you language that is much higher
quality right so it actually looks
better to to people
and the other benefit is for your
question earlier we 100 of the time
generate something that satisfies the
constraint because otherwise the next
token would have zero probability
okay while these previous methods they
were just kind of like best efforts you
know they would try to generate
something that looks good but they would
often get it wrong or Miss certain
keywords and so on
and so I think this is maybe a bit too
uh fancy of an application to really
dive into here but it should hopefully
motivate you that things like
marginalization are actually very
powerful even in the age of Transformers
and GPT
yeah so what we did here is actually we
just took the language model and we
we distilled from it I mean this is the
solution of machine learning terms but
essentially we find a PC a project
circuit that's very similar to it
that has small KL Divergence from the
Transformer
um that's that's the connection but
otherwise these are just two different
distributions an intractable one an
attractable one you compute
probabilities in both of them and you
have some way of aggregating them so
that's
practical model using data generated
yeah
yeah exactly
and the tractable model is really
nothing fancy it's just a hidden Market
model on the GPU with lots of parameters
but otherwise and with some fancy
training techniques but it's really just
a simple processing circuit
okay
um all right so all whatever Theory you
come up with related to marginalization
and generative models has a cool
application for people that like to
generate text that's the summary here
um and you're guaranteed to satisfy the
constraint because you're doing
reasoning you're actually doing logical
reasoning as part of probabilistic
reasoning
um and there are some other benefits and
you know the language of these
constraints you can easily generalize to
actually arbitraryological circuits and
so Eugene will talk about that later how
do we do marginalization when we
actually are given an event expressed as
a logical circuit
all right
um good
so one more topic for me to cover so
there's one more query that I already
mentioned which is a map inference and
so I would like to still introduce the
properties needed for efficient map
inference and also the algorithm to do
so
okay so suppose we have a circuit that's
smooth and decomposable and we would
like to do map inference which recall
means find a assignment to the variables
that are unobserved that maximizes the
probability under this distribution
all right uh sadly we cannot do so
because every time we have a sum note in
our circuit what we really have is an
implicit mixture which I hope I've
already convinced you of and we cannot
somehow push this maximization operator
over the summation
operation we could when it was an
integral we can no longer do it and you
know it's actually provably intractable
to do this map inference on a
decomposable and smooth circuit
luckily we can come up with another
property that if we impose it on the
structure we can still get map inference
and so this property is called
determinism which is arguably a terrible
name because it's not the determinism
that you intuitively think of but really
what it means is whenever we have a
mixture of two things
these component distributions have
disjoint supports meaning
for any possible world
we we get a bunch of zeros as our input
here except for at most one of these
components okay
so that's what determinism means and
it's true here because here we actually
have an indicator variable saying you
know this little distribution only
outputs something non-zero if X1 is less
than Theta and this distribution only
outputs a non-zero likelihood if X1 is
greater than Theta this cannot happen at
the same time so this is a deterministic
sum note
okay this is not a deterministic sum
node because for to for one possible
World both of these gaussians can give
you a non-zero probability so that's not
allowed okay so how do we deal how do we
actually use this property to our
advantage uh well let's look at the map
so the nice thing about this determinism
property is that whenever we have a sum
in our mixture model we could we could
write it as a Max because if I take the
sum of a bunch of numbers which are all
zero except for one it's the same as
taking the max of all those numbers okay
so Max and sum here are doing the same
work
and so therefore I have equivalently a
Max to my sum and uh the maximum X you
know we can we can alternate those
things and now we can push the max
inside of our circuit and we've moved it
to the second to last layer
hope this is intuitive I mean the key
part is
if at most one thing is non-zero Max is
equal to some that's really the takeaway
here
uh so now we are at this part of our
circuit we have a product so now we have
to maximize this distribution which
factorizes in a particular way we can
take the observed variables and kind of
split them left and right uh we can take
the optimization variables and also
split them left left and right and
really what we're doing is we're
optimizing an objective function and
just the product of two independent
objective functions that don't share any
optimization variables
and so it's pretty trivial to see that
you can just optimize them independently
and multiply the result okay and so now
we're again done we've taken our Max at
the output pushed it all the way to the
input and here we assume we can ask a
gaussian what its mode is we can ask a
coin flip what is your mode and we
actually get that answer
again the actual algorithm itself is uh
is using dynamic programming so we turn
the sums into Max and then we kind of
get the modes for some variables we get
the likelihoods for others and we take
Max of product of Max of product and we
get our output which is the probability
of the most likely assignment
okay if we care about the actual value
of the most likely assignment then we
essentially just have to trace back
where do the numbers come from don't
read the numbers they're actually wrong
but you kind of Trace back the the
numbers to figure out which choices for
the variables uh actually give me my
most likely uh State at my uh my my most
likely State my highest probability at
the output
okay other fun things you can do with
map inferences you can ask what's the
most likely type of every pixel and you
can do some fun applications with this
but again only only if you care okay two
more slides and then I hand it over to
yujang
um you may Wonder a little bit about
okay how how good are these
distributions when we learn them from
data maybe you don't really want to
learn all the dirty dirty hacks that go
into trading these models but the main
takeaway message here is that if you
train a probabilistic circuits on things
like mnist they would actually do really
well so this metric here sculpt a bits
per pixel or bits per Dimension it's
telling you essentially what is the
likelihood of every image and um here
you have a bunch of standard kind of
neural network architectures for
distributions and you can see here that
you need fewer bits per pixel to capture
the MS distribution here meaning it's
actually a better distribution than
things like variational Auto encoders
normalizing flows and so on and it's
it's it's it's essentially state of the
art among this kind of sets of
uh of neural networks
so surprisingly despite decomposable and
smooth circuits being trackable actually
fitting them to data can be done in a
way that's very competitive with any
other neural network architecture yeah
so how do you decide the architecture of
the probabilistic circuit right so
that's that's the stuff I didn't want to
get into at the very end of the tutorial
essentially for images there's a very
natural way to do so which is to kind of
partition your image Left Right top down
and create like large mixtures of like
patches essentially
um I can tell you offline or
maybe at the very end of the day but I'm
I'm hoping it's it's a lot of hacky
stuff
but it does work well in practice
so to follow up on that question so for
this mixture models for the images you
you don't really get the uh product
notes right you only get some notes is
that right uh not exactly so so for
example there's a paper at icml last
month about state-of-the-art image
models like imagenet 64 type of like
natural images and what what happens in
that paper is you take your image you
split it up into small patches you'll
learn that there's different types of
patch level small distributions uh you
essentially built a large mixture of
products of these different types of
patches
summary
so so yes you do multiply you kind of
pretend like patches are independent
because you multiply them but then you
have a very large mixture on top of that
that kind of glues them together so a
red patch is very likely to be connected
to another wet patch you know given the
fact that it's a red image that's kind
of the intuition
so you have a very deep secret or do you
have a
um
good question
it's not exactly balanced but we're
pretty close
uh yeah it's
roughly we'll log in depth I think okay
so there's a bit more but yeah
for images that make sense for language
it's different for language actually in
a market model trained as a proposing
circuit it's pretty close to state of
the art for tractable models and so
there you kind of follow this uh right
linear order of including variables one
by one
but Eugene will talk about that later
yeah
yeah so the structure of the circuit you
don't treat it as a part of the
parameters that you learn
so what are the parameters are they just
the number of this question so when we
train these things from data we train
for every gaussian of course it's mean
and variants or for every Bernoulli the
bias right or for every categorical or
the probabilities plus all the weights
of the edges that are associated with
some mixtures
so that ends up for these models I think
being maybe about 5 million parameters
or 10 million parameters for mist is
fine if you want to do things like
imagenet you need maybe a couple hundred
millions of parameters
um and more parameters is better steep
learning
how does the inference time compare to
standard elements it's faster because uh
well okay It's Tricky um
it's faster because often we can get
better likelihoods with smaller models
for some of these
these models they are and they end up
being very very large virtual Auto
enclosures that are quite slow
um
theoretically it's all just linear in
the number of parameters
so in practice it ends up being
competitive with this other architecture
because they have to really over
parameterize a lot at least for these
types of data sets
yeah
so many machine learning questions I was
hoping to avoid yeah
so this is without determinism if you
need determinism things are much worse
that's a good point you don't really
know how to scale up determinism
the max itself
very good idea there is work on
approximate map inference and for
example I think Dennis will tell you all
about it if you ask him yeah
these things are very expressive and
also very scalable so the models in this
paper which are from last month they
scale to billions of parameters and they
do really well on like natural images so
just so you know this is not just a not
only a theoretical exercise
okay uh so I hope I convinced you that
uh you know these models are interesting
I hope you kind of see what they are and
why they're correctable and so now I'll
hand it over to you Jang to tell you
about the connection to logic which
you're all dying to hear and then we'll
get also more into uh Advanced query
classes
all right
is the mic on okay sounds great
all right so
um let's start right off of course again
same thing please interrupt at any point
if you have questions I think geed
promised that I'll answer a lot of
questions
um so if if you know like well I'm
covering is not satisfactory please do
interrupt me and let me know
okay
um so how are these
um problem circuits that that we've seen
so far related to logical circuits right
so
um of course the thing hung pointed out
earlier
that you know like can can we you know
replace the the same ring from what
we've been using in the uh probability
of commutative simmering to to others
and still get this uh tripability right
um so of course we can do that
um for for instance what we kind of saw
earlier with uh map inference you can
almost see that as essentially replacing
um this with the max tropical semi ring
right like replace uh some with Max
product with a thumb
um there's also some um other work
extending this to other uh simmerings
um and and we get it's kind of like
algebraic circuits as well
um and one uh key key example of that is
of course the the Boolean semi ring
right so so by
um
by using Boolean simmering instead of
the probability uh semi removing using
we essentially get logical circuits so
now the circuits will have uh or an end
Gates instead of something products as
the internal nodes right
and um so so here similar kind of story
of uh alphabet soup of many different
different models that all show that we
can actually understand as different
sort of instances of logical circuits
right uh different um with different
properties
so those uh properties that that we've
seen so far actually has have you know
history kind of rooted in the uh
properties from logical circuit
literature so
we have the same ones we we've seen
before decomposability determinism and
smoothness with very similar definitions
except
um now instead of on
um some some nodes and product nodes
that will be defined on
um and Gates and or Gates and I'll also
get to some some more details about like
how how these uh properties can be used
for some The Logical queries
so that
um this kind of uh characterization of
different circuit languages using the
properties kind of induce this hierarchy
of
um hierarchy of different logical
circuit families you know where one
might be a subset of another family and
so on
and I'll get to more about the later of
you know which properties
um have some some of these uh families
have and and what does that imply about
their circuit sizes
right so
um
so how we use these logical circuits is
to do of course to do inferential to
answer different queries so starting
from for example a CNF right we would
compile it into a circuit
and then try to
um
answer queries you might have on this
compile circuit and the idea is that
when you're compiling
um if if you have
some query of Interest right when you're
compiling you would try to enforce the
appropriate pro circuit properties that
would get you you know trackability for
that query
so of course now the compilation might
be the the hard part but the idea is
that once you've compiled you can answer
many queries you know very efficiently
so the most basic kind is uh nnf circuit
I think a lot of you will be familiar
with a lot of The Logical circuits that
I'll go through so
NF circuit or a negative normal form so
if the negated normal part is basically
just that the negations only happen on
only occur in literals right so you can
have
um
we have literals and then the internal
nodes are just all all or in and Gates
so this is the the most you know basic
kind now we're not assuming any
properties here
so if we add one property which is
decompressibility same definition as
before
um inputs to the and gate has to
um or have to depend on this joints as a
variable
the Highlight is is very um
pale here but so basically if you look
at
um this node right
um all the inputs for the left or all
the variables in the in the left input
that we have K and L and then
on the right side here we have only p
and a so they don't overlap and same
thing with all the other end nodes and
and gates in this circuit a quick quick
question so um maybe people have noticed
this you're using these um useless gates
with that you at a k or not k
yeah so this is kind of the trick you
would use to ensure smoothness and
that's why you know once you if you have
decomposability to add smoothness you
would just add this kind of silly Gates
but the whole point is that
um you add them without changing the
logical formula but now you've
introduced the variable to ensure
smoothness so in this particular why do
you actually need K not not okay right
so if you if you don't have K here if we
if we just replace this side as as a
single
um l so this example is to kind of
later on also you know build and show
that we can use this for um queries and
there we would actually once moon is for
example if you kind of accounting but I
I got it so the top the top or the
topmost or is a k from the left because
that came from the left outside today
Center so you need it needs to have a K
in the middle and the K in the writing
yeah
yeah we want K in all of these
right so um kind of the
oh yeah
it's okay
exactly yes so that's the very first one
naturally
um so once you have a decomposable
circus then you can as they're said in
linear time and the algorithm is is you
know the mean you're talking about
algorithm is very similar to what we've
seen before is like starting from
um leaves and then propagating up it's
basically at the
um leaves you ask okay is this literal
satisfiable yes it's the single video
within the button yes if you have two
um
sub-circuits or like inputs to or gate
they're both or so that either one is
satisfiable then the gate is also
satisfiable and you keep going that way
right
um all also can get to some other
queries as we introduce more properties
I can't help but making this observation
that sat is essentially integration you
already want to sum up over all possible
assignments and see if you get at least
someone uh in in the previous episode
does for integration in order to do
integration you didn't need uh
determinism
yeah same thing so now when you actually
want to do counting then you foreign
just still um just means that
um
at most one of the inputs non-organ can
output a true in this case
yeah so that's not the same as xor
because you can have both
um or not both neither of operating
right
you would actually change the
the law school formula that you're
representing it if you know
and you have an or you can replace this
all by an axle right
and you are going to get the secret that
is equivalent
it wouldn't be equivalent because you
can have a deterministic
it would be equally right oh okay as in
as in just just
this picture like replace the gate as in
no I'm saying in general you know that
it's deterministic you're going to
replace an organic surgery
no no yeah so if you
if to an or gate
they were both false in this case this
is a deterministic or you want the
output of that a to be false so if you
replace it with
um xor now you're going 14. but uh
yeah oh I'm thinking it's okay
yeah yeah
you're right so that the wolf is one and
then you get zero and yeah
is it always the trailer success you can
read it please
uh is this always a treat except for
repeating leaves
no so we're watching
but even here like in general these
would be dags even if you um can be
diagnosis
can you
know it is an end and skeleton or
can you actually
imagine like here you could basically
just like
take this cake here and then connect it
to another
so here it would change the um
it would change the local formula but
that that is still a valid circuit and
it also be keeping possible but if you
have an and
and now you don't have the
um
they would have the dark structure is
because
I mean in the middle you can always
and have a dance structure okay the
ordinode can have shared common uh
descendants if you have an order
that needs to be deterministic
complicated condition but uh the the
left charge may share common notes with
the right chart lots of common notes
but not the end if you have an end and
they have come to be completed this
joint
what's an example of an unsatisfiable
circuit if you don't allow the constant
zero
because even and with X and not X you
can't have that right because it shares
I don't see how you get it unsatisfied
yeah so one example is that if you
imagine if you didn't have the
composability you could have
um like in the circuit if you have you
know yeah yeah I'm saying is there
example of a decomposable unsatisfiable
without the false yeah
I don't think so right I don't see how
it could possibly be ever be false
because you the ants are always on
disjoint sets of variables including
like you know the the trivial X and
nautics so maybe but you can probably
solve Sharps even with this so maybe
that's the interesting
sets whatever it's in this form but you
use this as a conditional set solver
where you're like if I set all these
literals to these values is the formula
still sets and that basically means
putting false in a bunch of inputs okay
seeing if it's still outputs true okay
so that's where it's useful okay right
this is Trivial right yeah yeah yeah
thank you
any other questions
all right so now
um
let's
add one more property which is uh
determinism so I think we already kind
of touched a little bit so basically
um same idea right only you
um one or for any input only one of the
um inputs to a or gate can be can
evaluated to True right so here kind of
graphically represented as these red
wires that are propagating true uh blue
I believe that's right yeah and then
blue wires that are propagating false
so you can check that
um you can see that in this particular
input
um
no for for any or node at most one of
the inputs value to true and then this
is actually a deterministic circuit so
it happens for any possible um input
so with uh
determinism added now we can also um on
top of that we can also answer query
called match set in in linear time which
is asking okay is
um the the is the majority of
um
potential assignments actually
satisfying this formula
another example that I actually want to
focus on is
um
model counting and weighted model
counting right and and that's because of
uh a collection of where the model
coming to probabilistic inference that
we've kind of focused on so far right
so with the decomposability and
determinism
we can actually in linear time answer
the model counting problem which is
asking for how many
um satisfying assignments there are and
then the weird model counting problem
which is a weighted version where it's
asking for the sum of all the weights of
the satisfying assignments
weight of an assignment is is just given
by product of the rates of literals
that's given um as as input on top of
the Boolean formula
so of course
um
model counting is just a special
instance of already model counting where
the weights are one
but okay so how does
this actually work very similar to um
integration that we saw before right um
you're just summing
um summing up values
over the the assignments
so the algorithm is essentially if we
have
um this Boolean circuit so if we had
some you know logical formula that we
compiled into a decomposable and
deterministic circuit
and some weights Associated weights
given what we do is
take every um
take every or gate replace it with some
nodes take every
and gate replace it with product nodes
and then
for all the literals that we had here
just replace them with the associated
weights you're given okay and then the
evaluation is just now same thing we're
just doing weighted something products
[Music]
right so so
we are here we're working with the
assumption that we've somehow compiled
the circuits while enforcing these uh
properties so there are compilers for
example like based on using like the
trace of dpll like solvers that will
actually generate
um you know circuits of of different
properties and often they guarantee
determinism and the possibility as far
as I know most of them like we don't
really know how to even compile like
without determinism they're um some work
but most of them actually always
guarantee these properties
any other questions
okay so I mentioned that um
there's a connection to um of with the
model counting to probabilistic
inference
so
to to say a little more about that
basically
um what we can do is reduce a
probabilistic influence think about
marginal inference task into a bit of
model counting task and how that happens
is is you can encode a probabilistic
model for example a Bayesian Network
as a way to model punching formula so I
won't go really into the detail of how
that encoding
um happens you can check out the paper
by uh Mark shavira and andarish force
some concrete examples
um but basically what happens is you can
you know
um introduce auxiliary variables and
then in the the formula in the
associated weights the parameters you
have on the Bayesian Network would for
example show up as the weights so that
when you want to compute marginals on
that visual Network you can translate it
into a
um really model counting task right so
there will be equivalent
so how we can actually solve it is once
we've encoded this compile this formula
into a logical circuit
um that is deterministic and
decomposable
and then by by doing very model counting
on that circuit you're effectively
solving marginal probabilities or
Computing marginal probabilities on on
that initial proposed model
and um of course the pictures is kind of
similar as what we saw before with
probabilistic circuits if you want to
answer more complex queries we would um
start enforcing more uh you know
stronger structured properties and also
go over some examples on that
so there is something I don't
know
right
for the probably six seconds to marginal
difference you don't need determinism
and I don't quite
understands why you have this difference
yeah that's a really good question so
why do we need determinism for weight
your model counting when for sums and
Integrations on on PCS we don't need
information so
um so
we don't need determinism on on PCS
um because for presumption products
basically what we're doing is whatever
the distribution is modeled by PC we're
saying once we have the composability we
can
compute arbitrarisons and integrals
right
um one way to think about that is for
logical circuits
we um when we turn a logical circuit
into a sort of arithmetic or like a
proper Circuit by you know changing it
to something products if we don't have
determinism it's no longer going to
represent a logical function meaning
your output might not be one anymore
your output might be larger than one so
it's no longer the same function so
that's when you need determinism and
then
to do counting that's
um you know decomposability is actually
playing putting the major part there
does that make sense okay
so one may I think about this is that
it's the same urine matters uh if you
compute if you do your integral over the
same meaning of reals then you don't
need determinants but if you do this
over the same urine of booleans uh where
you have item potents then
um you need determinants so algebraic
properties of the same Rings they matter
uh to your um for the complexity of your
algorithm yeah that's a very good point
like if you
need
um determinism
um so instead of actually you know going
into detail what this encoding and then
compilation
look like what I'll say is that
um
there's kind of a way to turn these you
know compiled uh circuits you know
coming from the way that model content
uh
formula to just probabilistic circuits
where the parameters actually just or
the weights just occur in the edges
instead of as these like new variables
on on the leaves of a or on on the
Boolean formula right so all I'll do is
actually show you how you can you know
directly translate some graphical models
um into probabilistic circuits
right
it's like a way to say that even about
this chunky note and or when you don't
have a better unit one side or the other
side one zero zero one but if a company
you need to know whether you need to
take care of this this is the reason why
you need your accounting on the top of
the brilliant smearing that's uh
that's it
okay
so I'll come back to some some more um
languages with with stronger properties
but let's talk a little bit about
um compilation from a progress model and
then and then I'll come back to more
circuline languages
okay so let's see okay we're starting
with kind of tree fission Network
structure we'll say we want to compile
it into a probabilistic circuit
using this example let me walk you
through what that looks like basically
compilation is going to be a bottom up
meaning we start from the leaf notes in
in this network and then recursively
compile a circuit going up
what we do is is
look at this Leaf node um we've got its
conditional probability table which
gives you
um you know given the parent see what
what's the probability of this variable
a in true or false okay
so how we do that is let's say this
um given that c is zero we have these
two parameters same probability of a
um in one is is point seven
given this condition that's e0 okay so
so that's
um one way to represent condition
and then given another condition
same thing
um you can represent this the coin could
prove this way
okay and then we'll do the same thing
for this other weeknote
and then I'll recurse so now we move on
to this pairing mode is a first of all
think of the probability of
that the variable conditioned on some
value of its parent so we have a similar
looking thumbnail here now we're going
to connect it to the corresponding
cases when we had C is up to zero right
so so the we're reusing the circuits
that we this tiny circuits that we made
earlier and we're connecting it
and so on until you've compiled the
entire network
so of course this is you know com now
this is going to be all over time
um
and and compact circuit if you're
starting from a tree and if you um
compiling a Network that has found a
tribute and you can also similarly bound
the the compilation
um time and size
so one example of a
tree network is hit a Markov model that
was mentioned earlier so it's using this
we can take
um
model and then compile it into a circuit
efficiently
so another
um example of how compilation could be
used is actually in probabilistic
programming for instance
um
so basically if you have like a discrete
probability program like this which is
essentially using a programming language
to define a probability distribution
what you can also do is take this
compile it into again a circuit in this
case
an example so that you can do you know
exact inference on that program
um by performing greater model counting
on the compiled okay
it's a compilation works for uh
so he
um yes for a utensil compiled by how
that works is a compiling Factor by
factor and also combining recursively
but then of course in the general case
you know um
in the most General case this the
confirmation can be hard because doing
inference on on Market random clothes is
also hard in general right
um so similar story is
the normalization factor
you know how they're computed in
about the partition functions
yeah so if you compile if you can
compile it into a circuit that is
decomposable then you can actually
compute the particular function there
right but then this is why compile
compilation will be hard
tell me
I think I have
two minutes so I'm a little hesitant to
actually start kind of the next part so
if you have a question I'm happy to
answer them
or I can
okay so let's thank the speaker then
[Music]
yes we have time for questions any
questions
the other question
right so I think that I'm trying to
confirm motivation so you have a
Nickelback if you've never had a
something a tree on that and then you
have your uh
is that like I want to ask those queries
like uh
you can uh Nar on the thing on the map
so I do interesting are you saying that
because we don't want to do those on the
network we can now use that
oh as in because during doing it
directly on the trees is like already
easy
right so so is it true that doing the on
the right is easier than a map
oh so in this case in the trick is this
is kind of uh just an example so it it
might be a little silly because here you
already have like a linear time
complexity so you're kind of going
through this work to still get you know
linear time
but in general so what happens is I
mentioned that you can kind of go
through okay I'm gonna have to go back
too much but I mentioned that you can um
take a problem model and then encode it
into a weighted Boolean formula
um and then compile that right so in in
this route what could happen is even if
the starting network doesn't have like a
bounded through like in in general case
there are
um
some cases where you can still you know
use some sort of Independence properties
of the distribution to get a compact
circuit so in that case
um you wouldn't be able to say that um
like or like you you wouldn't be able to
say that you know starting with the
network you're inference with
um easy but then in the composer okay
there may be cases where you can still
compile the compact circuit and still do
linear time like inference including
more assumptions
yeah it's what happens is like in the um
encoding in compilation you're looking
at finer grain independencies that don't
show up in the structure and then the
tree of it
and you can still like some exploit that
during compilation
yeah
do you have any uh upper mouth or the
size of the circuit that is combined so
it's attractable but but the complexity
of the
yeah so it would be
um bounded to the trivet I believe would
give you a bound on the
actual width of
yeah I think with the the circus
attributes to completion I believe
yeah and then the depth is of course
like at most and but I think there's
like tighter balance that is
your question is that uh you know yeah
you can do inference on the left or the
right but there's many models on the
left and there's only one on the right
which is kind of like you know build up
CPU for all programming language or you
can have a small instruction set
okay any more questions yes
for the three in the starting Network I
think yeah I mean like given the
compiled circuit we know
[Music]
this method will always get you smoothly
composable and deterministic circuits
usually what happens is different
compilers will give like guarantees so
depending on the compilation method for
example if you're compiling from a a
standard formula using some kind of like
trace of dpll what would happen is you
get like deterministic notes or or even
like stronger properties if I have time
I could actually get to later
right so the compilation could be it
could be very hard yeah so now you're
kind of
transferring the harder part to
compilation and once you've compiled you
can do linear time but the yeah the
caveat is that your circum might be very
large I see
okay so I think this is a good time to
stop let's thank you
so now launch on your own energy